hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to one night at flumpty's
now this is another five nights at
Freddy's clone that everyone would not
shut up about much like five nights of
[ __ ] boys it's just one of those things
it doesn't sound good but then everybody
is saying that it's good also five
nights of [ __ ] boys - I'm gonna be
recording on the day that you're seeing
this I've heard a lot of good things
about it so it's only one night so I
figured why not and the Seacoast is away
yes how's it go were you like oh
flumpty's gone you didn't say anything
about this actually being creepy why is
there a dinosaur on the toilet should I
be worried that flumpty is disappear a
well horizon flumpty dumpty hey how you
doing oh you so damn adorable you're not
I got a bad feeling about this what the
hell
wait man drinks lava and lives kinda you
should be watching the cameras I know
your worst nightmare running out of
toilet paper hey it's me it's my
markiplier symbol new door crimes
flumpty kidnaps person because he felt
like oh hey fluffy are you coming down
the other corridor now well ain't this
just delightful this it's weird because
this game is like animated but it looks
really good oh the little hey your face
is wandering a little bit off your skull
you worry about that why is this we're
all Wardley really wobbly boy okay I
don't like any of this Oh where's he
going flumpty bumpty
Oh flippity froo buddy ah boy okay well
I just noticed it like the door power
the door powers like separate from any
other power oh wait flumpty's already
gone oh hey how's gone you
hey where's your newspaper go I thought
you were dying so apparently you're a
badge beaver beads Babur okay that's
that's weird
all this is weird something weird is
going on here and I don't much care for
it maybe I do careful what is going on
with this one here some mysteries in the
Scott damn game I'm supposed to why is
there a hole in my that hole always
there is there always a big burned hole
in the middle of my office I haven't
been paying attention to a whole lot of
stuff when I probably should've been are
you like are you like the reincarnation
of foxy and I'm supposed to be wait a
minute poohbear wait what was that
always a death and destruction over
there I'm gonna assume that it was I
don't know if I set on the mouse cursor
oh it's only to I am I don't feel I'm
going to die I think that beaver
dinosaur is gonna come after me well so
what the hell is going on in the rest of
this I can't even tell what's going on
in the background I have a feeling that
it's changing um because it's just
subtly like in the back of my mind
something like that again
man this is so you you guys weren't
kidding when you said this one was
actually good this is like the best
working one oh you're both friends here
that's like the best working one I've
ever seen in my life I don't even know
never mind
you know what seriously what is going on
here this is like guy gases last level
in earthbound those to be able to see
back here is that like the kitchen where
I can only tell if someone's there
oh so all there's flumpty okay so that's
really weird flumpty ain't gonna die by
flumpty today hi hey whatever the hell
that is
oh man I'm already 50% power this ain't
good at all let's say good at all
they're both gone
great just dandy and fine hey is the
rest of my room decaying more and more
as time goes on I gotta have a bad
feeling that cetera oh boy oh boy okay
I thought the flumpty might have been
dumped teeing up my hallway this is
really creepy like no joke that's really
creepy
Oh Oh what is that the pinch of Tartarus
is that a thing as Squidward on the wall
here why is this a thing
distracted oh my god my eyes have been
turned into eggs alright be back and
unless I see something new I'll be back
to where I was like 4:00 a.m. [ __ ] this
is actually really well done because the
rules are forcing me to check the camera
to see if they're done so I have to like
check the camera to make sure I know
where they are really well done
where's flop day oh there's lumpy good
great oh [ __ ]
what is with that oh my god this is
actually really tense oh my god this is
really tense
this really tense oh my god it's like as
hard as any other five nights at freddys
I've ever done except I don't know the
rules whoa whoa whoa whoa there's a
cloud in my door there's a clown in my
wall I'm not worried about that I guess
okay I'll be back
I got focus on this one I got a focus
Abita I don't know what's happening half
the time why is there a clown calling
through my whole save that from a clown
fanfiction that goddamn beaver the demon
beaver beaver demon oh hey house corner
it's gonna make my life much easier you
to beat here it's good I like it you fun
friends coming down now should I take my
eyes off it for one gut oh oh how can he
come all the way over right two old keys
gone back alright well that's just fun
damn it damn it don't like that sound
come on for I am holy [ __ ] I don't even
know if the door powers like actually a
thing that I need to be worried about or
if it just kind of happens
that's that's a fun family reunion for
the whole family
flumpty ain't there
that guy's still there alright flumpty
over there you stay over there flumpty
oh look your friend joined you all that
clown sure it's getting close doll sure
I'm happy about all of this scenario
that we're in ah okay so the clown where
the cloud starts to peak is ugly headed
for him around the corner you can't
really keep your eyes on the camera
that's what I do that's what I do [ __ ]
okay back to 3m god this is taking
forever Jesus
we're gay okay okay man these nights
lasts a long damn time
that is disturbing and creepy and weird
and why is that a thing
wait why is that still thing I don't
like that I don't like that okay I was
operating under the assumption that he'd
already gone I didn't know I needed to
look in camera - but camera two was
blocked off [ __ ] it's about to be 4 a.m.
when that clown starts to come on poppin
on by and I gotta
this Oh the redness okay oh I get it
ah that's right the camera that was all
[ __ ] woogie D you know what I meant
[ __ ] - [ __ ] - [ __ ] - fugu crap why
is he already over there what am I
supposed to do about that maybe I'm
supposed to like close that that's the
only thing I can think of maybe I wasn't
supposed to be looking at it because
you're supposed to close and that's the
end of that I don't know I don't know
man I don't know man man me and I don't
know oh oh oh did I do it I think I did
it I think I did it right I think that's
what I was supposed to do I just kind of
wait till that one that's actually a
thing I gotta think of that as a thing
yeah okay all right now the coast is
clear
kinda probably okay all right
so I'm starting to understand it
understanding is half the battle here
because like they're all this is
estranged and unknown to me over there
sir man over there rounds over there
clown clown clown gotta pay attention to
the clown Jesus okay can't let clown get
away from grass oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] doc okay
so the clown is different the clown I'm
probably to go I have to go back to my
original assumption about the clown [ __ ]
and oh [ __ ] he's popping out more and
more each time I put my camera down
always flumpty damn it where's flambe oh
[ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] okay there there there
so I don't want to put my camera down
just yet when I run out of power
okay all right we're fine we're not [ __ ]
why do they keep doing that they make me
think that they're at my door and
they're not
oh I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] aren't I I'm
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
where's flumpty dammit [ __ ] there's
flumpty dammit alright that didn't sound
good come on why is it still 4:00 a.m.
dammit geez man that clowns gonna kill
me it's gonna kill me I guess I could
just leave the left door down because
the other guys on the red guys on the
way anyway I think I might be able to
last it out [ __ ] not anymore horseshit
that goddamn clown okay so he's back
that's good what okay I can't see
flumpty oh there's flumpty well I don't
want to put my door down Oh God okay
whatever good good it's good it's all
good
there's flumpty there it's gonna last a
little longer little longer longer it by
a little longer I mean a lot longer a
whole lot longer a whole bunch of lot
longer oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] shut [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that just killed me if that saved
my life or vomit or run out of goddamn
power but god damn is Oh
6 a.m. come on oh you [ __ ] ah I know
that fight if I put my camera down one
more time oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] me hey hey
that's going there
how much takes Emmys back to the pit oh
hell they crawled out of my teeth
featuring flumpty bumpty and birthday
boy blam everybody's favorite birthday
and the beaver everybody loves it a good
beaver and the red man who was clogging
up the toilet with his grundle and crunk
clown oh and golden funk I didn't see
golden flumpty if any of you saw Gordon
flumpty maybe on the comments below this
was actually really well made I'm very
surprised anyway there's a sequel to
this game if you want to see it let me
know in the comments below otherwise
have a wonderful day thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see
hey to put up the thing